[Musique]
c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
seraient les bienvenues sur france 24 à
la une ce soir la flambée du variant au
micro en côte d'ivoire le pays a
enregistré 78 kg ce mercredi les
autorités sanitaires avaient constaté
une forte hausse de cas de grippe avant
de constater qu'il s'agissait du nouveau
variant du coc vide nous serons à
abidjan dans ce journal cette polémique
en république démocratique du congo la
société civile du territoire d'uvira
dans l'est du pays dénoncent une
incursion des forces burundaises pour
traquer une rébellion cette présence at
elle été autorisée par les autorités
congolaises les précisions de pascal ou
lesgoirres correspondant de rfi à
kinshasa dans un autre j - 4 avant la
poule au coup d'envoi de la can au
cameroun la coupe d'afrique des nations
doit débuter dimanche l'heure est aux
derniers préparatifs ce soir on vous
emmène à bafoussam dans l'ouest du pays
où doivent se jouer huit matches c'est
également dans cette ville que vont
séjourner les lions de la teranga
la côte d'ivoire connaît actuellement
une flambée de kobe 19 avec une
multiplication par cent du nombre de
contaminés en quinze jours à titre
indicatif mardi mille cas ont été
détectés pour la seule journée de mardi
pour un total de près de 74 mille cas
confirmés depuis le début de la pandémie
les autorités avaient constaté à ces
dernières semaines une étonnante montée
des cas de grippe pour finalement
admettre qu'il ne s'agissait pas de la
grippe mais de covin 19 la
correspondance de samuel bernard
voilà deux semaines qu'une supposée
épidémie de grippe fait la une de la
presse en côte d'ivoire douleurs
musculaires difficultés respiratoires
maux de gorge les symptômes rapportés
évoque pourtant bien le co vie de 19
mais l'arrivée de l'harmattan ce vent
venu du sahara qui rime chaque année
avec des épidémies saisonnières crée
aujourd'hui la confusion en côte
d'ivoire
face à l'incertitude hier c'est la
directrice de l'institut pasteur qui a
pris la parole selon elle il n'y a pas
de doute il s'agit pas d'une épidémie de
grippe mais bien du côté de 19 écoutez
les signes qui ressemble à de la grippe
a tellement dans la période où nous
sommes c'est du coc vide il faut il faut
pas se cacher actuellement quand
quelqu'un tousse quand il a mal à la
gorge quand il se sent pas bien
dans 95 % des cas c'est du coc vide est
le seul moyen pour le savoir c'est
d'aller faire le test se faire tester
voilà donc le maître mot mais cela n'est
pas si simple à abidjan par exemple
seuls les tentes dédiés sont habilités à
faire des tests pcr les hôpitaux qui
accueillent les malades ne peuvent donc
pas les tester mais seulement les
soigner difficile de répondre à une
épidémie dans ces conditions
l'alternative pourrait venir des tests
rapides qui sont désormais disponibles
dans la capitale et que les autorités
soient développées en côte d'ivoire les
cas de kobe 19 sont passées
quotidiennement du tice à 1000 ces
derniers jours avec un pic à 2815 le 31
décembre dernier
ces questions soulevées en république
démocratique du congo les troupes
burundaises ont-elles franchi la
frontière congolaise avec la bénédiction
kinshasa ont elles été autorisées à
traquer l'aller rébellion burundaise
dans la province du sud kivu après le
déploiement des troupes ougandaises dans
l'est de la rdc la société civile du
territoire d'ouvir à la zone concernée
par ces incursions dénonce une énième
violation de la frontière congolaise les
précisions du correspondant de rfi et de
france 24 à ce qu'elle voulait voir
selon des sources locales puis des 300
soldats burundais serré entre la rdc est
reparti du 19 décembre dernier dans les
territoires d'uvira province qui fit
kivu une semaine durant ces longs chef
de groupement local l'émirat ils ont
traversé le plateau qui surplombe ce
territoire se soldant l'ancien dimanche
dernier leurs attaques contre les
positions des rebelles burundais des
raids tabara ces groupes est considéré
comme le plus actif des groupes rebelles
burundais dont la base arrière et dans
l'est de la rdc depuis une dizaine
d'années il revendique régulièrement des
attaques au burundi le groupe affirme
avoir affronté dimanche les forces
nationales de défense du burundi mais
aussi les imbonerakure ces jeunes du
parti au pouvoir burundais les seins des
fdd seul un court communiqué du groupe
rebelle ces affrontements ont fait au
moins 10 morts et une vingtaine de
blessés cotherm et burundaises la
société civile d'uvira assure avoir
alerté l'armée congolaise desquels les
troupes sont entrées en rdc mais dix
jours après aucune réaction officielle à
kinshasa la question est embarrassante
pour les autorités soupçonnaient par la
société civile d'avoir autorisé l'entrée
des troupes burundaises sur base d'un
accord secret avec dite eca
nord-est de l'actualité en bref et en
images le retour de l'ambassadeur
d'algérie en france après trois mois
d'absence mohamed tahar djaout va
reprendre ses fonctions une reprise qui
devait mettre un terme à une grave crise
diplomatique avec la france à la veille
du 60e anniversaire de la fin de la
guerre d'alger en tunisie l'homme fort
du parti islamiste ennahda nourdine cris
arrêté vendredi est hospitalisé deux
jours plus tard à accepter d'être père
faisait soigner âgé de 63 ans l'ancien
ministre de la justice avait décidé
après son arrestation d'observer une
grève de la faim et refuser de pain ses
médicaments l'émissaire de la cedeao
pour le mali s'est rendu à bamako
l'ancien président nigérian goodluck
johnatan avait pour mission de
transmettre à l'homme fort du mali le
connaît la semiga goïta un message
quatre jours avant la tenue d'un sommet
une réunion est prévue également à accra
avec les chefs d'états et de
gouvernements ouest africains pour été
menée la feuille de route soumise par
les autorités maliennes
comme chaque année le ministre des
affaires étrangères chinois effectue sa
première visite à l'étranger sur le
continent africain une tradition
instaurée il ya 32 ans pour montrer à
l'importance de l'afrique aux yeux de
pékin cette fois ci les comores
l'erythrée et le kenya sont au programme
wang li est arrivé aujourd'hui à naïrobi
pour une visite de deux jours les
précisions de notre correspondant
bastien ennuis
physiques le kenya moins de deux mois
après son homologue américain anthony
blinken et si les deux super puissances
se sont donné rendez-vous dans le pays
d'afrique de l'est ce n'est pas pour
rien ils veulent montrer au kenya bien
que le pays compte au niveau
international et chacun a sa stratégie
côté américain c'est plutôt une
stratégie militaire les américains sont
basés au kenya à proximité de la
frontière somalienne il z les troupes
kényanes dans leur guerre contre le
groupe terroriste al shabab côté chinois
c'est plutôt une aide économique qui est
apporté les chinois sont présents dans
absolument tous les domaines ici au
kenya notamment dans les infrastructures
où ils investissent massivement ils sont
derrière le train qui relie mombasa la
capitale ils sont tous derrière les
routes derrière les portes il est
beaucoup au niveau des énergies à chaque
fois il apporte de l'argent de la main
oeuvres et des connaissances
technologiques mais il y a un revers de
la médaille notamment selon les
économistes et les analystes financiers
la dette kényane a explosé au cours des
dix dernières années plus de 4 milliards
de dollars dont 67% sont détenus par la
chine mais du côté du gouvernement et
bien on s'en félicite le président
auront kenyatta qui va bientôt quitter
le pouvoir après deux mandats à la tête
du pays est bien se félicite du
développement des infrastructures du
développement du pays au cours des
dernières années sous ses deux mandats
et il s'apprête même à signer de
nouveaux contrats avec le ministre aux
affaires étrangères chinois lors de
cette visite d'état
bring back à horgen zh ramener nos
filles c'était le mot d'ordre il y as
attend lors de l'enlèvement de trois
cents jeunes filles par des djihadistes
dans un collège de chine boc au nigeria
à l'époque la mobilisation était à la
hauteur du choc provoqué par cet
événement dans l'opinion internationale
depuis les kidnappings pour obtenir des
rançons se multiplient dans
l'indifférence samedi 21 enfants ont été
libérés par la police nos confrères de
france 2 en tant qu était sur ce fléau
national un document signé nicolas
bertrand et marianne getti
dans toute la moitié nord du nigeria les
habitants vivent dans la crainte du
projet d'enlèvement
ils ont particulièrement peur pour leurs
enfants qui sont les premières cibles
ici plus de 1500 jeunes nigérians ont
ainsi été kidnappés en 2021
dont la grande ville de kaduna cette
université est un des établissements qui
ont été attaquées les cours n'ont
toujours pas repris neuf mois plus tard
francis paul étaient présents cette
nuit-là dans son dortoir quand les
ravisseurs ont donné l'assaut ils ont
marché vers ici
j'étais là à l'intérieur dans mon lit
sauf là donc j'ai vu les lampes torches
quand nous sommes sortis ils nous ont
dit nous allongé par terre ce spot tout
ce mic frau lyng camarade de chambre a
essayé de s'enfuir
ils lui ont tiré dessus
il était blessé au ventre et au genou
francis est enlevée avec 38 autres
élèves
le groupe est conduit à marche forcée à
travers champs pendant plus de 18 heures
jusqu'au camp des assaillants en pleine
forêt une rançon a bien été payée mais
les autorités n'ont révélé ni le montant
ni l'origine des fonds
même quand je repense à ce qui s'est
passé j'ai l'impression que c'était hier
je suis toujours traumatisé je ne vais
vraiment pas bien
les ravisseurs ont pris exemple sur boko
haram mais lors seul objectif c'est
l'argent et pour ça ils sont prêts à
tout jusqu'à exécuter les otages
voici la chambre de dorothée
et voici sa folie totale
dorothée étudié les sciences politiques
dans une autre université de kaduna elle
a été enlevée et tuée avec deux autres
étudiants dont dix dates sauzeau fait ça
juste pour que l'école et les parents
sachent qu'ils étaient sérieux à propos
de la rançon de un million et demi
d'euros ils n'ont pas de coeur s'il
avait des sentiments humains il ne
pourrait pas prendre des gens au hasard
comme ça des lives et ses enfants sont
innocents complètement innocent
ceux qui sont censés les protéger
l'armée et la police nigériane
souvent accusé de corruption sont
incapables de mettre un terme aux
enlèvements en moyenne treize personnes
sont kidnappés chaque jour dans le pays
rêver devant notre caméra pourtant les
forces de l'ordre veulent montrer
qu'elles travaillent
ici ces policiers contrôlent les
véhicules et affirme mettre tout en
oeuvre pour cent le courage la bravoure
de nos agences de sécurité je vous
assure que ces problèmes auraient
dépassé ce que vous pouvez imaginer
images faut une attaque que vous voyez
est à moi qu'il y en a plusieurs que
nous avons évité pourtant à peine le
convoi reparti les policiers de terrain
eux n'hésitent pas à nous confier leur
désarroi dans cette guerre leurs ennemis
sont bien mieux équipé je suis découragé
par ce que leurs armes sont meilleurs
que les nôtres
quelqu'un qui a une mitrailleuse tu ne
peux pas l'affronter avec une
kalachnikov comme ça de très nombreuses
écoles ont dû fermer dans toute la
région et des millions d'enfants sont
privés d'enseignement à cause du risque
d' attaque
et d'ailleurs les chiffres sont aussi
très parlants burkina faso plus de 3000
écoles ont fermé leurs portes cinq cent
mille élèves se retrouvent des
scolarisés à cause des violences qui à
10 selon le gouvernement cela représente
13 % de l'ensemble des structures
éducatives du pays
alors que la coupe d'afrique des nations
doit débuter dimanche au cameroun
bénévoles et organisateurs effectué les
derniers préparatifs à bafoussam où
doivent se jouer huit matches la ville
de l'ouest du pays s'apprête également à
accueillir l'équipe du sénégal les lions
de la teranga doivent y séjourner pour
la durée du tournoi laurent vers stecher
au stade omnisport de bafoussam ces
bénévoles attendent de recevoir leur
accréditation officielle ils sont près
de 300 à avoir été sélectionnés pour
participer à l'organisation du tournoi
et malgré la fatigue la motivation est
là car dans quelques jours le sénégalais
le zimbabwe disputeront ici leur premier
match de la coupe d'afrique des nations
en
fin de partie
alors que l'as cannes doit débuter
dimanche l'excitation est palpable dans
les rues de bafoussam car en plus des
huit matchs qui se joueront dans son
stade la ville de l'ouest du cameroun
accueille également l'équipe du sénégal
l'une des favorites du taux non nous
sommes très fiers de ça dit d'accueiller
les frais sénégalais chez nous a pas
fait ça nous sommes fiers et hacker
sajama n'est pas sa seule star africains
qu'on a besoin de voix
mardi sadio manet et les siens recevait
les encouragements de leur président
macky sall avant de s'envoler pour
bafoussam vol qui a dû être décalé suite
à la détection de trois cas de co vite
19 au sein de l'équipe sénégalaise
voilà c'est la fin du journal de
l'afrique merci aux équipes en régie
merci à notre chef d'édition célia
karacena et merci à vous de nous avoir
suivis rester avec nous la faut
continuer sur france 24
[Musique]